dj
is with us in st louis hi dj how are you
hey guys how are you i'm doing well
great how can we help
well um i am graduating in may with my
master's degree and i'm already starting
to job hunt
and one of the issues i've ran into is
that many of the employers that i'm
looking at
want x number of years of paid working
experience and
i'm just curious as to how i could
either a circumnavigate getting paid
experience or be make myself more
attractive to them to want to take a
chance on me
what's your master's in exercise
physiology and
my field of study is cardiac
rehabilitation
okay so what are you applying for
cardiac rehab
yes sir okay yeah you for any of those
health professions man
there's a season whether it's
a medical doctor or whatever
nursing tears where you just got to go
in brother and start grinding it out
and put your time in and get to know
folks there as our friend ken coleman
talks about
get next to people at the first job you
can take
and grind it out and grind it out and
show people that you are going above and
beyond click in for extra shifts when
you can
and um you may not be able to go
straight into the job you want but if
they want three years of paid experience
and they see how you hustle after one
year then they may pick you up and move
you on
i had somebody do that for me they took
a third year that wasn't really a third
year
because it was three years required and
they
they counted it because they saw how
hard i was working
and what i brought and the skills i
brought to the table yeah but you're
gonna have to get in there and grind it
out but there's no way to circumvent it
in the
in the health care field especially in
the one you're doing man because they
can't make a mistake there
because the mistake gets somebody killed
right and so the liability there
the expertise and wisdom there is
there's not a lot of corner cutting
going on
[Music]
if it was another field and i don't know
how this applies to yours and and john
may be sitting here telling me
with his answer that it doesn't apply
but if it was another field
i would almost be tempted to find a way
to eat
for six months and offer to work for
free
or for three months let me come in and
work for three months and prove to you
and i
won't charge you a dime now obviously
you'd have to have oversight
and whatever where they had a comfort
level with your competence so someone
didn't get harmed
to john's point and i don't know how
that kind of thing would work in the
medical world it's probably
harder to do that in that world than it
is in the business world
as an example but if um if i have
someone that doesn't have experience
we're thinking about hiring a marketing
position and you've got a master's
degree you're straight out of school in
marketing
um translation you don't know beans
about marketing
right exactly you just gotta masters is
all
oh sorry sorry but you don't uh you've
never sold anything to anyone except
your professor for a grade
and so uh you know but you come in here
and you're sharp and you hold the
interview
and you offer to work for three months
for free to prove your worth
that you can add value we would not let
you do that but that would be
such an impressive offer it would make
us give you a chance of some kind or
consider it if the only thing on the
table was
that you were fresh out of school and we
don't hire a ton of people fresh out of
school hardly any
in here most of the people we hire are
have had at least one position before
they come here but we do occasionally
yeah and but again it's any organization
net net is looking to see can you add
value
more than you cost right and that's what
any
employer is hiring for i tell our team
all the time i'm real straight with them
you have to make more than you cost me
otherwise this thing's going to fold up
right that's how this works and so there
has to be an roi on everybody here
including old dave right and so
um otherwise it folds up like a cheap
tent
and so uh but that's if you can figure
out a way to get your foot in the door
on something and be
willing to work for free and deliver
pizzas at night
and you use that for uh to pay your rent
and to keep your lights on and keep a
little food on the table and you do that
for six months
i don't think you're going to do it for
three years but if you can get your foot
in the door is that any possibility that
would work
yeah but i don't think it's mutually
exclusive i think he could get a job
work in the front counter
at a place and then ask hey when you do
this type of surgery or when you start
this head prehab can i just go watch
or can i come in on saturdays or can i
come after my shift is over can i watch
at least get in the door right so when i
was when i
got my first job out of college which
was coaching high school
um basketball and track and and being a
teacher there in houston
when the varsity coach was cutting
people i went and asked him i've never
seen somebody get cut i want to be
can i just sit in that room and watch
that conversation and he looked at me
great guy and he said sure come on in
don't say anything and
it was a hard but i got to watch up
close
a a man of integrity tell a young man
you didn't make the team
and it was hard to watch and it was hard
to be in that room and you got to feel
the room the tension in that room and
the
students who would get mad you'd see i'm
sorry that's how i began to learn and
then a couple years later i was able to
say
hey no i've been in rooms where there's
hard conversations we've had this and
then i had to start doing it right with
my own team so
it's putting yourself in a situation
where you can be successful and
yeah grind it out and pay the bills yeah
hang on i'll have kelly pick up i'll
give you a copy of ken coleman's book
which is really the best answer to your
equation
and it's what we're talking about it's
called um the proximity principle
it is the number one or it is ken's
number one best-selling book
uh the proven strategy that will lead to
the career you love
the proximity principle and that's what
we're saying is get in proximity
of people who are doing what you want to
do even if it's not ideal
and that gets quote unquote your foot in
the proverbial door
i also think before you take this call
dave this is a
a good lesson for everybody
just because you got a master's degree
doesn't mean someone's going to hire you
and there is a gap between getting your
bachelor's degree you race through and
get a master's degree well suddenly
you're going to require too much salary
for me to hire you and you don't have
enough experience to back that salary up
and so there is some wisdom sometimes to
going to work for a year or two
take go to school at night or adjust
your schedule so that by the time you
graduate with this master's
you've got two or three years of paid
experience under your belt
and you haven't out priced yourself for
the uh the
work experience that you have yeah i
don't know in that field if it's a
master's required to get in the door i
don't know i can't imagine they would
let you
work on patients without a graduate
degree i wouldn't think no i wouldn't
think
so it might be a little different step
but the uh you know for instance a
master's in business is certainly not
required
hardly anywhere right major corporations
you know but you don't work for them
anyway right so um
you know it's a horrible situation yeah
but but i mean we've got people in the
building here with mbas but
um we really care whether they get crap
done we don't really care whether they
have an mba
i wish you'd been there the day i asked
the hr director hey where did i sit in
my transcripts and he looked at me
like i said i asked him oh yeah
can you do the job john that's the
question at the ramsey office can you
get the job done your raise is effective
when you are
that's right